eu vou falar um pouco de futuro e tem 37
são coisas diferentes
como a mesma coisa mas elas são bem
diferentes no futuro a gente projeta
gente dentro desse universo de inovação
comunicação tecnologia o futuro está
muito mais uma linha que sai de
tecnologia então olha o que está
acontecendo no mercado o óleo que os
desenvolvedores estão fazendo ea partir
disso tem entender com o mundo vai
evoluir nesse espectro de tecnologia a
tendência é diferente é muito mais
focado em comportamento
então baseado no que estou vendo que eu
converso que eu vejo que eu falo com as
pessoas
o mundo tem de andar por esse lado é
interessante como as tendências são
construídos socialmente e culturalmente
ela sempre podem mudar
então por isso que a partir do momento
que a gente lê uma tendência a gente lê
que algo está acontecendo a gente pode
impactar para que isso mude um pouco do
que eu vou falar aqui tem a ver com isso
as pessoas me procuram muitas vezes né
eu acho que vai acontecer né e não tem
bom domínio de bola principal num se
você pegar o olhar e falar o mundo está
indo para um lado isso vai acontecer é a
visão da singularity que a gente viu no
primeiro bloco a palestra sobre o
fundador
também acho que a coca cola não vai
salvar do mundo
já na visão muito de tecnologia muito do
futuro né
eu acho legal esse otimismo esse
pragmatismo é é a tecnologia exponencial
de tudo o que isso pode ser
possibilitada a disputa que pode
acontecer mas do outro lado tem um ser
humano a gente precisa se questionar e
saber para onde o que a gente vai fazer
com isso né isso é muito poderoso isso
de fato pode mudar o mundo isso pode
corrigir algumas rotas erradas que a
gente tomou no passado né
então eles vão entrar num questionamento
maior
eu vou dar um volta passado então como
eu disse sempre que a gente vai olhar a
tendência a gente tem que olhar o
passado tem que fazer um recorte olhar
porque aconteceu que tinha naquele
contexto o que acontecia e a gente tem
por 144 milhões de anos não daria pra
olhar pra comentar e fazer uma fala que
de menos de 20 minutos passando por
todos esses períodos
então a gente resolveu eu resolvi pegar
e fazer um corte dos últimos
anos nos últimos cem anos quando a gente
pega a revolução industrial é um marco
que impacta educação impacta a sociedade
como um todo
um primeiro momento a gente consegue a
gente como sociedade e serve todo mundo
no consumo na então se antes ficava
restrito a quem tinha ou que existia a
possibilidade de comprar algo cortesia
democracia na empresa assim como a gente
queira chamar agora não é hora de ter o
operário mixto operário fazendo criando
a gente pensa o outro titular civil e
essas pessoas podem comprar agora elas
são inseridas na na na sociedade de
consumo e aí a gente começa a criar uma
possibilidade de todo mundo pode comprar
o que é muito legal o que é muito digno
que é muito justo ea e publicidade entra
matando a pau ea publicidade começa a
vender e os bancos começam fazer cada
vez mais linhas de crédito e as pessoas
começam a desejar mais coisas começam a
comprar já se começam a ficar loucas
atrás de de posse né
isso vira uma coisa maluca porque daí a
pessoa começa a se matar de trabalhar
para conseguir comprar mais e ela compra
mais e ela tem que se matar de trabalhar
com a viola já amarrada com crédito e
aquele sonho americano da casa própria
do carro na garagem da família comendo
margarina de manhã
como assim tá todo mundo a gente olha
posso falar vamos mais então meu pai que
cobra que o trabalho não vai também que
a gente comece a faltar uma sociedade
muito fortemente do consumo na a gente
chegar e nos anos 80 existe um consumo
individual muito grande então começa a
querer comprar não só uma casa para
minha família
um carro pra minha família o começo ele
comprar produtos pra mim né então é o
boom da moda né
chega agora no fast fashion eu vou
comprar roupa pra mim eu compro relógio
comprou computador com tudo e começa a
comprar esse consumo desenfreado com
certeza ele tem um candidato bem colocou
o impacto muito grande e aí enfim eu com
as pessoas à sua volta se começa a
discutir a gente trabalha muito o
mercado começou a se perguntar que tudo
acontecerá já em 2015
nunca se consumiu tanto quando se
consome hoje de tudo que vai acontecer
daqui pra frente na qual o futuro disso
e a gente acha que eu acredito isso ele
está vivendo a sexta extinção está se
matando 21 nomes futuro
não tem nada daqui pra frente não tem
nada a gente não e preferir não é a coca
cola que vai interferir não é a
tecnologia por si própria que vai
definir a gente a gente cabe a gente né
então alguns dados 99 por cento de todas
as espécies que já habitaram a terra tão
distintas a 1.101 pontos na verdade um
ponto porcentual os mamíferos estarão
extintos nos próximos 30 anos isso já
dado detalhes todas as espécies
desaparecerão até o fim deste século não
falam do próximo ou falando aqui tinha
15 anos 600 mil
estou falando de 90 anos os habitats
naturais estão todos destruídos sendo
destruídos aglomerado de pessoas nas
pessoas procuram os centros urbanos para
viver se ampliando cada vez hince
confiando em espaços menores e cinco
pessoas morando ali 30 anos morar lá ter
uma possibilidade tão bom trabalho e
poder comprar mais porque no final das
contas trata de isso desmente falar
disso superexploração dos recursos
naturais mudanças climáticas causadas
por tudo isso né
lógico que a gente fala da obsolescência
programada como se fosse algo novo a tal
marca fez isto não é isso que existe
desde os anos 50
as coisas são feitas para estragar a
gente compra mais rápido ea gente entra
uma roda maluca de cônsul
então no final das contas se a gente não
mudar para travar essa gente não vê o
fim do planeta nossos filhos e netos
enfim isso é uma questão de pouco tempo
e aí eu trabalhando na bota na incerteza
no mercado e trabalhar com o cliente que
sempre na frente de casa para vender
mais um produto e depois eu vou na
agência de publicidade dele não sei quem
participa de reunião com a agência que
há muito difícil o cara quer vender mais
produtos e aí o pessoal me falou cara
não posso falar pra ficar bem demais
o flamengo vem - ou então falar pelo
vento ou melhor né
você não se trata mais de volume a gente
não pode mais
aqui ó acabei de passar rapidamente
o episódio mostra que não tem mais como
esse ritmo de dever e daí de compra se
manterá o preço irá bem no boxe e
falésias tem que fazer um movimento que
a gente vai ter que bancar a e acho que
tudo tem um impacto da mudança envolve
muita coragem em volta você chegar e
falar cara seguinte não vem da mais você
não pode criar mais produtos na loja de
vôo ea gente trouxe a perspectiva de
você precisa entender que você precisa
comunicar você agência precisa comunicar
você empresa precisa produzir um produto
melhor se vai vender menos
ele vai decidir ser de melhor qualidade
que você precisa incentivar o seu
público a comprar menos
ele precisa desacelerar porque senão não
tem mais mundo pra ninguém pra cá
agência pro cara da empresa pra mim pra
vocês pra todo mundo e aí foi nesse
sentido que a gente chegou nesse
conceito a gente começa a trabalhar
direto a partir de 2015 2014 de luxo
mesmo é basicamente tiraram o pé do
freio
existem várias outras alternativas de se
trabalhar o mercado então basicamente a
nossa mensagem é ser mais consciente
você tem que questionar série a2 comprar
a icera que não de erros é que eu
preciso
será que eu faço com isso dentro de toda
essa perspectiva é consumir menos e
consumir melhor escolher melhor o que eu
vou comprar e comprar todos ainda tudo
não é só a casa carro é a cerveja o
restaurante que eu vou é é a roupa que
eu vou usar e é existe uma questão muito
interessante que dentro dessa lógica que
a gente falou tecnológica e aí sim em
volta é assim talvez possa se tem uma
visão otimista da tecnologia
a gente tem uma mudança de comportamento
se a gente consegue entender que de fato
a gente precisa mudar o nosso
comportamento
aí sim eu acredito na tecnologia de você
poder pegar essa tecnologia e
potencializar a mudança do mundo
esse despertar da consciência
basicamente até - a exige menos você
pode trabalhar - você pode consumir
menos
você pode exigir coisas melhores de
melhor qualidade
você pode acompanhar toda a cadeia do
produto desde onde foi implantado o
tomate que você vai comer na hora que
chega no seu prato entender que é só a
cadeia toda pode ser mais justa
isso é difícil né porque num discurso
muito bonito mas no final das contas
também está falando de sabre mão de
muita coisa nessa abrir mão de certos
privilégios ou de certas posições só que
todo mundo está disposto a ganhar um
pouco menos trabalhar um pouco menos
consumo menos uma reflexão que não é tão
simples apesar de parecer e muitas
iniciativas já estão na cdu já estão
respondendo a isso né
então por exemplo que tipo de economia
na gente viu hoje aqui o vídeo com a
economia mais sustentável colaborativa
coletiva na coletiva extremamente
importante já que a gente consegue se
conectar a outro
só que a gente também não pode propor
mais a trocas não quero mais essa calça
mas ela não tá velha guarda no guarda
roupa e comprar uma nova
eu simplesmente não posso procurar
alguém para trocar o igor
o conceito de sucesso ressignificado a
gente vê essa geração nosso trabalho com
muita gente nova super complexo assim
como funciona a cabeça né
a pessoa já está nascendo no mundo onde
ela vê isso e ela metralhada por essas
informações o tempo todo
mais do que isso ela sente isso né uma
em são paulo é uma cidade a qualidade de
vida é super contestável na enfim
poluição trânsito esgoto a céu aberto
onde poderia ser um rio a um rio na
verdade né monte de dilmas faltado uma
criança que nasce hoje que daqui 15 anos
e 18 anos ela vai questionar porque o
mundo para aquele
não é porque ele está asfaltado
naturalmente não vai chegar nas
respostas mas condiciona as respostas e
ela já está significando o sucesso para
ela o sucesso pra ela não é mais fazer o
que os pais ou então os avós fizeram pra
garantir que ela tivesse aquela posição
mas aquela condição horrível que ela tem
né ela mora no bairro super legal
ela mora num 70 restaurantes bons mas é
hora de repente não pode andar a pé são
paulo sabe o repente ela não pode fazer
um exercício paulo por ter menos
saudável do que ficar em casa porque
você respira um monte de poluição na
tela já está disposta e eu percebo isso
e jovens do trabalho de 18 19 anos
não adianta chegar pro cara o que falar
vou te dar um aumento vou te dar mais
dinheiro a disse que se trata é a
alimentação que eu falei um pouco né da
origem ou não desperdice a procuradoria
por um mundo mais holístico então esses
valores a gente começar a buscar a um
propósito na nossa vida né
se você tira o protagonismo do consumo
naturalmente você abre uma frente ou
várias frentes para entrar na sua vida
daí com certeza se você vai trabalhar -
se você se dedicar menos pra comprar
bens materiais está abrindo espaço pra
novas atividades motivações
compensatórias não é isso vou me dedicar
um pouco alinho me dedicar à minha
família ou amigos a uma causa
à saída da cidade isso é uma coisa que
está acontecendo muito forte de novo
trazendo a perspectiva de piora de são
paulo
pessoas da minha idade que estão
largando tudo vou pro campo vou para a
praia
vou fazer um ano sabático vou pegar tudo
isso que acumulei acumulei todos possa
perder repensar minha vida o que de fato
não faz mais sentido
o ato de compra passa a ser visto como
um ato social
o ciclo completo do produto virá
preocupação
enfim no final das contas a provocação
toda a gente faz o convite que eu faço
aqui pra ficar como reflexão é adotar
uma postura não souberam sempre consumir
menos e têm de que pequenas atitudes
podem gerar grandes impactos
então quando eu deixo de comprar uma
roupa por excesso
já tô dando alguma notícia já tocando
alguns sinalizando algo para uma loja
para o mar por uma empresa
esse volume de pessoas fazendo isso
cresce o recado está dado muito forte
então o movimento deve ser colocado em
prática com gente não tem mais como
continuar consumindo nessa velocidade e
por fim acho que a grande mensagem é
sempre tenso antes de comprar
a gente pode trocar a gente pode doar a
gente pode fazer é aguardar e depois
pelo menos nesse pé pode emprestar pode
fazer muitas coisas buscar alternativas
com menos impactos para os recursos
naturais
troque concert faça e vive apenas com
necessário esvaziar por essa percepção
da gente com certeza consegue evitar -1
[Aplausos]